sixty years ago this month Esquire
magazine released its golden age of jazz
issue featuring that photos seen there
in the Tom Hanks movie the terminal the
picture shows 57 legendary jazz
musicians gathered in front of a Harlem
townhouse in 1958 now a new book reveals
the story behind that historic image
have you been back here since that day
[Music]
benny golson is one of the great tenor
sax players a composer of jazz standards
like killer Joe a member of the Jazz
Hall of Fame
Golson was also a member of the elite
group of musicians who gathered on this
Harlem doorstep in 1958 do you remember
this day 60 years ago I remember it like
it was 24 hours ago do you really I
remember everything about it Wilson will
be 90 next week had just moved to New
York to join Dizzy Gillespie's band when
he was invited to a photo shoot at 17
East 126 Street did you know what you
were coming to not really all my heroes
and then I said to myself what am I
doing here
he didn't think you were worthy 58
musicians showed up the photograph would
capture the Giants of jazz Count Basie
sitting on the curb Dizzy Gillespie
fouling with Roy Eldridge Thelonious
Monk and Charles Mingus Jerry Mulligan
and Gene Krupa Coleman Hawkins and Sonny
Rollins imagine said one of the
musicians if everybody had brought their
instruments and played how would you
describe this group cream of the crop so
show me where you are in this I was at
the very top you were wherever to die at
the very top
[Music]
Golson is one of two surviving musicians
from the photograph
and the only one still performing I
didn't think it was gonna make it this
far
I'm glad you did what a surprise
this picture was your dad's idea it was
Jonathan Cain's father art Kane was a
hotshot young art director in 1958 he
pitched the idea of the picture to
Esquire magazine for its golden age of
jazz issue the concept here was just
really to assemble as many great people
as possible your dad really wasn't sure
on the morning how many people were
actually gonna be but he really wasn't
it was an act of faith the new book art
Kane Harlem 1958 shows frame by frame
how the musicians began to gather for
the 10:00 a.m. call time what was the
atmosphere like first word that comes to
my mind as we loaded yeah you never had
that many musician of stature
Moana Hinton wife of bass player Milt
Hinton took these home movies that day
there was no money involved I don't know
if there was catering I seriously doubt
it there were no stylists know stylists
around what you really had were were 58
brilliant artists who came for the love
of their craft Kane's vintage contact
sheets show there were distractions as
he tried to take the big picture a horse
and buggy going by Street peddlers
passing kids on the curb and the
musicians themselves who were all
excited to see each other
I think famously my dad rolled up in New
York Times into a megaphone shape and
started imploring people to please move
up into the steps did you have any sense
of that day of what a big deal that
picture would be none whatsoever when
the magazine came out this one I bought
it of course and that turned to the pic
Smith said boy that's a great picture
yeah in like old magazines you keep it
for a while and I finally threw it in
the trash you did I threw it but people
fell in love with the photograph right
away you know and over time the the
legend of this picture and its impact on
our culture has just has grown it's it's
really taking on a life of its own art
Jane's career as a photographer was
launched that day his future subjects
would include Aretha Janis Joplin and
the who Benny Golson became a composer
and arranger scoring music for TV shows
including mash Mission Impossible and
the Partridge Family but nothing was
quite like the morning he spent on this
Harlem doorstep
this was unforgetable magnum opus sixty
years later how do you feel about being
in that picture I feel like it was a
privilege on the day we met benny golson
the new owner of the brownstone came out
to give him a copy of the magazine he'd
thrown out all those years ago
16 years old Brad can you believe it and
I'm going to treasure this until I'm
dismissed from the element of time such
a lovely guy benny golson i should
mention the other musician jazz musician
great was still with us Sonny Rollins
who's 88 I also mentioned that there
were 58 musicians who showed up but only
57 are in the picture because one got
tired and sat on a mr. shott imagine
getting the invitation citing today I'm
sure they were worried a lot of them
wouldn't show but they were stunned when
some of the people showed up and then
what three showed up there were three
who showed up too late
Oh classic